Stick around to the end of this video to see
the top 5, coolest, best Things You Missed
in IT (2017).
Before we get into the Top 5 Things You Missed
In IT, let me tell you about the worst one.
In this deleted scene, if you zoom into the
movie theater marquee you can loosely make
out the title of the 1988 film, Mac and Me,
but what's interesting is what you'll actually
find in an infamous scene from that movie.
Roll it.
"Stoooopp!"
So guys, we did it.
We reached a quarter of a million subscribers.
Ahhh that was a terrible meme.
But genuinely, genuinely, thank you for supporting
me.
Thank you for sitting through this meme, and
yeah, here's the actual video.
Number 5: References to locations from the
book.
Stephen King’s novel, It, comes in at over
1100 pages long, making it impossible to fit
every scene into the adaptation.
Many of the scenes that were not included
are referenced via easter eggs, like the intersection
of Witcham and Jackson where Georgie loses
an arm, which is also the exact spot a home
in the old Derry township was burned to the
ground in 1741.
Tracker Bros Trucking was truck depot where
the kids of Derry liked to play baseball,
which Eddie revisits and faces manifestations
of It as an adult.
Ben’s school project is the Derry Standpipe,
and when he drops it, it becomes dislodged
from the ground.
This is where Stan has his first encounter
with It, and the location where some kids
had drowned in Derry’s past.
He can also briefly be seen going through
memorial park which is adjacent to the standpipe
and a victim of It named Stephen Johnson turns
up there in the adult era.
Beverly’s father works maintenance at the
Derry Home Hospital, where many residents
of Derry were born and where the younger brother
of Edward Corcoran dies.
Richie sports a shirt for Freese’s department
store, a business that he runs into in the
book to take refuge from an angry Henry Bowers.
The Black Spot is briefly touched on in the
movie, it was nightclub that was burned down
by an evil cult in Derry’s past.
That brings me to another tragedy of old Derry.
Number 4: The Bradley Gang Mural.
As the Losers try to get some medical supplies
for Ben, he and Richie stay out in the alley
where there’s a huge mural depicting one
of the stories told about Derry’s past in
the novel.
The Bradley gang was a group of gangsters
wanted for bank robbery and murder who had
come to Derry in 1929.
Practically the whole town came together to
shoot up the gang’s car, and witnesses recall
a circus clown joining in on the carnage.
Although Pennywise isn’t seen initially
in the painting, It has the ability to manipulate
the town, and shortly after the clown can
be seen watching them in the alleyway...
Speaking of clowns, there are a lot of secrets
hidden in…
Number 3: The Clown Room.
Richie wanders into this room inside 29 Neibolt
Street where he’s faced with his worst fear.
“Clowns”.
I’ve already discussed this reference to
the TV mini-series adaptation of It, but in
addition to that, there’s a clown statue
that turns it’s head, this picture that
I just find particularly creepy, and the model
Richie finds of himself which matches his
earlier prediction about what happened to
Betty Ripsom.
“You think they’ll actually find her?”
“Sure, in a ditch all decomposed covered
in worms and maggots, smelling like Eddie's
Mom's underwear.”
"Shut up!"
Number 2: The Turtle
Millions of years ago when It was created
by the celestial force known as “The Other”,
another entity was also created, and this
was The Turtle, essentially the rival of It.
The Turtle subtly pops up here and there in
the book to help the Losers Club, and there
are a couple of similar references in the
movie, like the LEGO turtle that Bill finds
in Georgie’s room, the model of the walkie
talkies that they use, TRTL 500, and the turtle
that touches Richie’s foot in the quarry.
“It’s a turtle.”
Number 1: The cosmic origins of It.
This isn’t really explored in the movie,
but the novel alludes to It and The Turtle
being the original inhabitants of an outer-dimensional
void known as the macroverse, and in one scene,
we see It crash landing on earth from outer
space.
However, fans of the book will be pleased
to see some small nods to It’s cosmic origins,
like the solar system setup in Bill’s room,
the reach for the stars poster in the library,
the moon poster and globes seen in Ben’s
room, the alien spaceship found in Georgie’s
room and Ben’s shirt during the projector
and Neibolt scenes.
These have been the Top 5 Things You Missed
in IT.
If you want to see the full 94 Things You
Missed then click the video on the left.
And remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for
new horrors every week, ring the deathbell
for notification and I’ll see you in the
next one.
Assuming we both survive.